Alice a big victory for you after
yesterday disappointing game against
Rochelle how did you come back
psychologically for from that loss
of course yes it's sort of tough I got a
bad opening and then she was able to get
a good petition and after that I was
able to equalize but the queen end game
he sort of grinded me down
um so today I was just trying not to
lose because like you know if you lose
you just don't want to have back to back
losses
um so yeah I just tried to play a solid
see as possible that's a very
experienced strategy in general
people your age they want to come back
immediately right they're like I want to
play some Sicilian some crazy Sicilians
gambits and just to get a try to get a
win yeah I mean today's my birthday so I
actually did it
yes happy birthday I just didn't want to
lose so like um I played E4 E5 and I
actually haven't played this before
um and then he played Knight C3 which I
wasn't expecting since I think usually
in the past she's done Knight F3
um
yeah he went for this one so I hadn't
really reviewed this line before the
game so I sort of knew what to do but
um I also like didn't so later on Knight
C6 Queen E3 Bishop B4 Castle I think
this is all wrong good
um you can also take with a rook at this
point which Anastasia was showing take
with the rook and then you cannot take
back because if I take C4 yeah but
taking with the Knight is also fine yeah
I think the line after effects before
that I looked at before was like broke
days before
um oh no after uh Rick takes E4 the
previous move I think Bishop F4 was what
it was and I actually didn't remember
what to do here
um it seems like Queen F6 might be the
best move and then I know that there
were some really crazy lines here but
I'm glad that she didn't go for them and
she did Bishop takes B4 after that uh
yeah I worked it before and I take
before both possible but I thought that
she got A3 either way so it'd be the
same position uh yeah so rookie eight
and and then she played this move Queen
to G5 offering the queen trade uh were
you surprised by this decision yeah I
definitely wasn't expecting it because I
thought any Queen trade would be good
for me
for me but because I was worried that
like she might do queen takes up six at
some point uh which would be slightly
annoying like not necessarily a queen
takes F6 is their idea right now but I
thought like if she you go Bishop yes
she respects and like Queen takes f63
takes F6 and yeah H5 it doesn't really
look that um amazing as though like I'm
still slightly better she might
eventually get like that five square
Knight H4 Bishop F5
um yeah so so you didn't want to see
your Pawn structure shatter yeah I mean
I was mostly considering a 95 after this
but then I thought like Queen takes F6 G
takes F6 Knight D4 and I guess uh Knight
takes D3 check is good here
um but I didn't really like this for
some reason
um and it makes a lot of sense I mean
Rook G3 is coming this night is pretty
powerful in the center the material is
quite limited so it's not easy yeah so I
decided to do queen takes G5 I wasn't
sure how good of a decision this was in
the game since like it opened up the H
file so yeah I was expecting her to yeah
I didn't expect Bishop B2 actually
because it allows me to do Knight D7 and
then I wanted to Knight f8 next which
well not necessarily right over here but
if she ever like does Rook H1 then
Knight f8 will just defend everything so
after C4
um yeah I think this was all good things
are simplified a little bit and then
here uh yeah I played Bishop F5 so I was
getting a bit low on time here and I
still had like 12 more moves 13 more
moves to make
um and I Snoop like after Bishop F5
Knight takes B7 uh Rook C8 King D2 Rook
C2 King E3 birthday C2 birthday C6 I
wasn't sure what to do here but like I
saw maybe I could try like Rook B3 and
94.
so you're not risking much yeah uh but
she played Bishop takes B7 which I was
hoping
um because now I can play Knight D7 and
she probably missed this move because
like if you aren't looking like
sometimes these background might moves
are hard to see
um and also like Knight takes C7 Bishop
takes D7 worked before then I have A5
and then after she moved to work uh then
the rook and the bishop are in the pin
and I'll be able to win an exchange if
you go here Bishop C8 if you go Rook B3
Bishop C6 yeah very nice everything
works out uh fine for you and after that
you went on and converted a nice
Advantage Alice congratulations you're
still in the chasing pack for the
championship we'll let you rest then
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
congratulations on your birthday Alice
13 years young wonderful wonderful
wonderful and uh I thought about it
actually is
this show which Alice is running I mean
how did actually come out with this idea
and actually
is it in your plan to become a
commentator one day
I don't know I mean I've done some
commentating with Jessica in the past so
I do have some experience I think for
now I'm just focusing on playing good
chess good for you yes you can wait
commentary go go and win all the titles
you can and then come back and be a
commentator that's the way it works good
luck Alice uh well done well done